Welcome back to mCoding!
Hopeyou're having a great day.
attrs is a library to help you
write Pythonclasses
in a simpler, less error-prone,
and lessboilerplate way.
It offers similar functionality
to the built-in dataclasses library.
And in fact, dataclasses
were originally based onattrs.
Very commonly,
when I write a class,
I need to define an __init__, __eq__,
a __repr__,maybe a __hash__, __lt__ etc.,
And most often, all those functions
are complete boilerplate.
Whocan even remember all of them?
And if I do, yeah, maybe
procrastinate on actually filling them in.
__init__ means self.something= something,
for each argument,
__eq__ means check
self.something= other.something, andso on.
If I want to add
or remove an attribute,
I now have to add or remove
it in all ofthese places,
which is both a huge waste of my time
as well as a very likely place
where I make a
typo and break everything.
Enter attrs and other
dataclass like solutions.
Instead of writing all that,
they write it for you.
Delete all that flaky, error-pronecode.
Here's how you write it with attrs.
Let's watch that again because
it was so satisfying. Nice!
You can also customize the generated
code usingparameters to define
or by using thesefield
objects on individual attributes.
This is implemented by
posting wrongcode to Stack Overflow
and waiting forsomeone
else to write it for you.
Justkidding,
it's this `@define` decorator.
It could also be done
with a metaclass.
But attrs and dataclasses both take
the decorator approach instead.
At this point, you may feel your
knee jerkingupwards,
telling you that this is
too much forbidden magic.
But fear not.
After thedecorator runs, the result is the
plain old class that you would have written yourself.
We can eveninspect, say, the __init__ method
to see the source code it generated:
self.something = something, andso on.
Exactly the boilerplate we wanted to avoid.
No magic is happening when
you use the class.
Theplain old boring repetitive
code is still there.
And the resulting class is just as
efficient as if you had handwritten it.
It's just that you didn't have
to handwrite it.
While the logic of
this decorator is complex,
ultimately all it's doing is
using your annotations
and whatever parameters to write
the source code of each function in the class.
And then it executes that code to create the
function objects and stick them onto the class.
But pretty much everything I've saidapplies
just as well to dataclassesas it does to attrs.
So why do I prefer attrs?
To be clear, dataclasses
are still great.
Andonce they came out when
they were first released,
I started using attrs less and less just due to their
convenienceof being built into Python.
But in the past year, the tables
have really started to turn.
And I'mchoosing attrs over data
classes more and more.
The first reason is slots,
which is kind ofa superficial thing
because both attrs and
dataclasses support slots.
But attrs makeslotted classes the default,
and good defaults are surprisingly important.
I have a whole videoon slots
if you want to check out the details.
But the short version is that normal Pythonclasses are
basically syntactic sugar around a dictionary.
And just like a dictionary, they can
have arbitrary new keys/attributes added to them.
In contrast, a slotted class has
a fixedset of instance attributes,
which makes it slightly
more efficient,
but also, thisprevents a very
common bug from making a typo.
If I accidentally try to set
`user.nmae= JAMES`
instead of getting an error
on a normal class,
I would just silently create the `nmae` attribute
on my instance, leaving the old name unchanged.
There's no error. I just now
have incorrect datain my application.
Can't wait to ship it to a customer, only for
them to tell me every namein a database is null.
But on a slotted class, as soon as
I try to set the `nmae` attribute,
I get an error telling me
I've done goofed again,
telling me `nmae` isn't
a valid attribute.
Whileit's certainly possible that you want the ability to
dynamically create new attributes on your classat runtime,
it's far more common for classes to
know all their attributes ahead of time.
Soit makes sense for slots
to be the default.
But like I said, attrs and dataclasses
both support slots, so what's the problem?
This brings me to my second reason:
Versioning.
Dataclasses are part of the
Python standard library,
As Python develops, more and morefeatures
like slots are added to dataclasses.
But if I want to use those features,
I needto upgrade my version of Python,
which may involve convincing a client to upgrade
and/ordrop support for an older version of Python.
That might not be acceptable.
And in a world wheremany companies
are still using Python 3.8,
that means no slots if I'm using dataclassessince
they aren't supported until Python 3.10.
In contrast, if attrs introduces
a new feature that I want to use,
all I need to do is bump the version of attrs
ona per-project basis, which is super easy to do.
And reasons three, four, five, and so on are allof the features
that attrs supports thatdataclasses just doesn't.
In particular, attrs supports validators, converters,
and factories that take a `self` parameter.
And it allowsyou to set
specific `on_setattr`  hooks per attribute.
So you could, for example, make only
one field frozen but allow the others to change.
Another superficial one: attrs recognizes
the importance of immutability
and gives you a top-level `@frozen` alternative
to definethat just sets the frozen parameter to true.
These are all little things. But when
you usea tool like this every single day,
these little things really
start to add up,
which is why Ifind myself using
attrs more and more in 2023.
Let me know what you think!
Do youuse attrs?
What about dataclasses, or do
you prefer handwriting all your classes?
Thanks for watching!
Thank you to my patrons and donors.
Slap that like button an odd numberof times.
And I'll see you in the next one.
Do you have a Python or C++ project
at yourcompany that needs a bit of love?
Well, my company does consulting.
So check outmcoding.io
to see if I might be able to help.